Le Café de
l'Espace des sciences avec la revue
Science Ouest,
puis Bonsoir.
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous.
Merci d'être nombreux ce soir.
Présent au premier café de l'Espace
des sciences de l'année.
Cette rencontre est organisée par l'équipe
de la rédaction du magazine Science
Ouest qui est un mensuel de l'Espace
des sciences
et je vous invite à découvrir justement
le dernier numéro, donc
le numéro de janvier, que mon collègue
vend juste derrière la technique
qui est consacrée au nucléaire.
C'est le numéro de janvier.
Pour rappel, l'événement pour ceux,
pour celles et ceux qui ont l'habitude,
mais ceux qui y sont peut être nouveaux
parmi nous.
L'événement est enregistré
et sera disponible en podcast
sur notre site internet.
Vous pouvez poser vos questions
au fur et à mesure de notre conversation,
mais pour cela,
il faut pas hésiter à lever la main
pour qu'on puisse vous donner un micro
pour bien vous entendre
et surtout que vous soyez enregistré aussi
pour que le podcast soit bien
bien complet.
Donc n'hésitez pas vraiment à intervenir.
On est là pour ça.
L'idée, c'est vraiment
de discuter ensemble de ce sujet.
Et justement, ce soir, nous allons parler
climat avec une question centrale
comment le réchauffement climatique peut
mettre ou Mais déjà notre santé en péril.
Nous avions consacré un dossier
à ce sujet il y a quelques mois déjà
que vous pouvez aussi
découvrir et qui sera
certainement très complémentaire
de ce qu'on va dire ce soir
et pour lequel nous avions interviewé
notamment
nos trois invités que j'ai vraiment
eu le plaisir d'accueillir ce soir.
Alors, tout de suite à mes côtés, Estelle,
dont vous êtes responsable ?
Bienvenue.
Déjà si bonjour, vous êtes responsable
développement durable et responsabilité
sociétale à l'Institut Agro à Rennes.
C'est bien ça, c'est ça ?
Alors je suis basé à Rennes,
mais responsable de l'Institut Agro.
l'Institut agro regroupe donc trois écoles
Rennes, Angers, Dijon et Montpellier.
J'ai un background en santé environnement
et maintenant je forme.
Après avoir formé les cadres
de santé publique pendant un moment
avec Cyril, le HSP.
Maintenant je pars.
Je suis parti
pour former les cadres de l'agriculture
et l'agroalimentaire sur ces sujets là.
D'accord.
C'est bien, Ça nous présente vos missions
dans les grandes lignes,
mais c'est très intéressant
et je pense qu'on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir, bien sûr. Merci beaucoup.
Nous avons également à votre côté
Luc Aquilina.
Vous êtes enseignant chercheur
au laboratoire Géosciences à Rennes.
Du côté de Beaulieu, là, c'est ça ?
Oui, tout à fait. Du côté de Beaulieu.
Ma spécialité, c'est les eaux souterraines
et plus globalement,
le fonctionnement des systèmes
aquatiques de surface souterraine.
Et je travaille pas mal
depuis quelques années
sur l'impact du changement climatique
sur la ressource en eau.
D'accord, merci beaucoup.
Merci aussi d'être là.
Et puis pour terminer, Cyril Harpe,
vous êtes chercheur
à Le HCSP à Rennes, également
enseignant et chercheur.
Ou est ce que je tiens
à la comparaison des deux ?
Tout à fait. Vous avez raison de dire
que le HCP et l'Ecole des hautes études
en santé publique, on forme
principalement les cadres de la fonction
publique hospitalière et non hospitalière.
Je tiens à préciser que les futurs agents
des administrations
qui se trouvent à la fois
dans les ministères
ou dans les agences régionales de santé,
dans des établissements de santé
ou médico sociaux aussi.
Donc, c'est
un public très large et en quoi
on peut les intéresser à ces sujets là ?
D'accord.
Donc je pense que vous allez
être tous les trois très complémentaires
et si je comprends bien,
vous vous connaissez déjà ? Oui,
Alors
on a un passé sur l'eau avec le campus
et on mène actuellement avec Cyril.
Des projets aussi de recherche
sur les inondations en Normandie.
Couple à la fois des aspects
justement sur la circulation de l'eau
et l'impact à la fois social
et économique.
Alors, j'aimerais commencer
en soulignant l'annonce
toute récente du programme Copernicus,
qui est le programme d'observation
de la Terre de l'Union européenne
qui a annoncé que les huit
dernières années ont été les plus chaude
jamais enregistrée dans le monde.
Je pense que ça pose le contexte.
On a encore tous en tête l'été dernier,
qui a été particulièrement alarmant.
On a vraiment vécu des moments
de très grande chaleur.
Le thermomètre a affiché à plus de 40
degrés dès le mois de juin en Bretagne
et des incendies ont ravagé
des milliers d'hectares,
notamment dans les monts d'Arrée.
Donc la région a
été particulièrement touchée.
Et bref, le réchauffement climatique
est vraiment là
et les scientifiques sont unanimes
Je pense que vous allez approuver
que ce n'est que le début.
Malheureusement.
Et donc nous,
on a vraiment voulu aborder ce sujet.
Pour vous parler de l'impact sur l'homme,
parce qu'on le sait, c'est établi.
L'homme est responsable
du réchauffement climatique.
Mais on oublie souvent
qu'il fait partie des premières victimes.
Car oui, le climat affecte
la santé humaine et je pense que ce soir,
on va pouvoir en tout cas aborder comment
et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire quand même.
Alors avant toute chose,
je vous propose, si ça vous convient,
de peut être partir, de commencer
par les principales conséquences directes.
Parce que justement,
on parle de la chaleur de cet été,
l'épreuve de la chaleur.
Est ce qu'elle peut impacter directement
sur notre organisme, sur l'être humain ?
Je pense notamment à la déshydratation.
Mais il y a peut être aussi d'autres,
d'autres aspects
qui peuvent être complètement déréglé.
Peut être le sommeil,
les cycles hormonaux.
Voilà, je voulais voir avec vous
comment, déjà, pour donner quelques
éléments de réponse sur les conséquences
directes sur l'être humain.
Cyrille peut être que
vous avez, pourquoi pas un éclairage ?
Ou alors vous balayez un petit peu.
Je suis dans une école de santé, mais
je ne suis pas moi même du corps médical.
Ça c'est important.
On confond santé et médecine très souvent,
la médecine apporte une première réponse
aux problèmes de santé qu'on a rencontrés.
Mais la santé publique, au sens
général, c'est ne pas attendre
nécessairement d'être en mauvaise santé
pour faire quelque chose.
Je tiens à le préciser, c'est à dire qu'on
a tout intérêt à être dans la prévention
ou la promotion en santé.
Plutôt que d'attendre.
J'allais dire à la dernière minute
pour se faire soigner.
Donc le propos liminaire
pour dire En santé, il
n'y a pas que des médecins,
c'est ça que je voulais dire.
Donc je suis anthropologue de formation,
donc je m'intéresse à l'homme
dans toutes ses dimensions.
Et pour un anthropologue qui regarde
l'historique de l'homme, de son évolution
d'abord, il a tenu aussi à s'adapter
à différentes situations climatiques.
Il faut quand même le dire, s'adapter.
Ça a été des conditions de vie
pour toutes les populations humaines.
Jusqu'à maintenant, face à
des aléas climatiques comme on va en avoir
demain ou déjà on en a
et on en aura encore d'autres demain.
Ça, c'est le premier élément
que un impact sur la santé ? Oui,
on le vérifie à titre
individuel, ne serait ce que
quand on connaît un épisode de canicule.
On le sait,
les répercussions que ça peut avoir,
on le sait sur le plan physiologique,
c'est très bien
réalisé maintenant par les physiologie.
C'est à dire ?
En gros,
on voit les perturbations que ça entraîne.
Rythme cardiaque ?
Bien sûr, parce qu'en fait, c'est ça,
ça fait des sacrés de dérégulation
du fonctionnement.
Le métabolisme.
Bien sûr, il y a des effets thermiques
liés à l'eau et donc la déperdition.
On parle du stress hydrique,
d'un manque de l'eau de l'organisme,
donc il va compenser avec d'autres
réactions.
C'est
les régulation thermique de l'organisme.
Mais ça veut dire qu'on s'adapte aussi.
Ce que je voulais dire,
ça perturbe notamment les plus fragiles
et surtout ceux qui n'ont pas été préparés
suffisamment.
S'adapter, parce que
combien de populations vivre vivent
dans des conditions climatiques extrêmes
depuis des générations, en
y ont trouvé des stratégies d'adaptation
qui sont à la fois physiologiques,
comportementales
et peut être que nous,
on a un peu oublié ça dans nos cultures.
Alors je vais reprendre une formule
que Jancovici
utilise On a des exosquelettes, ça va ?
Vous dites de quoi il me parlent ?
Un exosquelette ?
On a créé des environnements
technologiques pour se protéger de tout.
Donc on pense que plus
on a des exosquelettes
et plus on va pouvoir effectivement
se prémunir des aléas de l'environnement
et on en oublie l'environnement
qui est fortement perturbé.
Et ça a ses limites.
Alors c'est
une façon de répondre à votre question.
La santé, elle est impactée ?
Oui, mais on a aussi des capacités.
Les potentiels d'adaptation.
Merci.
Est ce que l'un d'entre vous
veut apporter un autre éclairage ?
Rebondit
sur les capacités d'adaptation comme
on sait que ça va continuer à évoluer.
J'aime bien parler de cette référence
qui a un certain âge mais est
récente puisque le film est ressorti
il n'y a pas longtemps.
C'est d'une.
Finalement, on a des capacités
d'adaptation, même dans le désert.
On voit dans Dunes,
ils ont l'exosquelette puisque leur
leur capacité
à faire leurs combinaisons technologiques
leur permet de s'hydrater avec eux
en urinant en soin dans leur combinaison.
Donc, on a
aussi toutes ces capacités technologiques
qui fait qu'on a une adaptation,
mais on en oublie
effectivement notre environnement
et on en oublie ce côté atténuation.
Il faut arrêter de faire évoluer
le. Il faudrait arrêter en fait c'est
limiter cette évolution du climat.
Mais pour l'instant,
si on va s'adapter, on va s'adapter.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ?
N'hésitez pas.
Oui. Bonsoir, on va vous donner un micro
dans tout ce que vous dites là.
Est ce que vous avez tenu
compte de la pollution atmosphérique
avec tous les rejets
de produits dérivés
du pétrole, du charbon, et cetera ?
La consommation,
même les essence, les voitures hybrides ?
Il y a toujours un carburant
qui avec un pot d'échappement maintenant,
peut être certainement mieux réglé
qu'auparavant, mais quand même,
qui laisse des particules fines
dans l'atmosphère et qui peut
avoir des conséquences importantes.
Malgré tout, une question
allez y, je viens en partie vous répondre.
C'est une très bonne question déjà,
et je vous remercie de la poser.
Alors on va distinguer deux phénomènes
la pollution de l'air
et le changement climatique.
Si vous en êtes d'accord,
la pollution de l'air, c'est
essentiellement
la contribution de nos activités humaines,
donc principalement
des produits d'origine fossile
qui sont qui rentrent
dans les combustibles.
Vous prenez les véhicules individuels,
tous les moyens de transport,
les chaufferies,
les systèmes de chauffage.
C'est la transformation énergétique
avec des combustibles d'origine fossile.
Je dis fossile,
c'est l'extraction
de toutes les matières premières
qu'on a fait depuis plusieurs siècles.
On a commencé par le bois, c'est
un combustible.
Mais là, la contribution du bois,
bien sûr, c'est aussi une pollution.
Si vous êtes à côté de foyers
qui ne font qu'émettre des cheminées,
on a une pollution aussi.
Puis on a eu les charbons et le gaz,
un gaz naturel gaz artificiel.
Et le pétrole,
c'est quasiment 90%
des sources, des ressources transformées
qui vont être émises dans l'atmosphère.
Ça, c'est notre pollution.
Et dans cette pollution,
il y a la partie du dioxyde de carbone
dont on vous parle tant, donc le carbone.
Le carbone n'est pas à proprement dit
un polluant qui va vous affecter
sur le plan santé, sauf le monoxyde.
Bien sûr, on le sait dans l'habitat,
mais ce n'est pas à proprement dit
un polluant qui affecte la santé humaine.
Par contre, c'est celui qui est incriminé
dans le gaz à effet de serre principal.
Qui contribue à quoi ?
À ce phénomène global du gaz de gaz
à effet de serre ou d'effet de serre
qui fait que votre rayonnement infrarouge,
quand il a atterri au niveau du sol,
il repartira dans l'atmosphère en restant
comme sous un couvercle d'une marmite.
Et c'est ça
qui produit l'effet de chaleur.
Donc on vous disait changement climatique,
On vous disait longtemps
on a dit réchauffement climatique.
En fait,
il n'y a pas que du réchauffement.
C'est une température moyenne
globale qui augmente que l'on observe
depuis plus de 150 ans.
Mais vous voyez la différence
entre une pollution que vous subissez
vous localement dans une ville fortement
polluée ou à côté d'une usine
n'est pas nécessairement en lien
avec les émissions de dioxyde
de carbone
qui viennent en recouvrir l'atmosphère.
Une sorte de
On dit souvent dans l'exercice
qu'on fait de la fresque du climat
une sorte de édredon
qui va vous réchauffer.
Ah ben oui,
ça va nous réchauffer. Ça, c'est sûr.
On peut s'attendre
à des degrés progressivement.
Vous savez, ce n'est pas la même chose.
Est ce que je suis assez clair dans.
Voilà donc ce que je voulais dire
par là, c'est que notre souci aujourd'hui,
localement, c'est la pollution de l'air
parce que nous,
on en subit déjà
les conséquences sur le plan sanitaire.
Le dioxyde de carbone, lui, on va en voir
les effets dans les années à venir.
C'est un effet à long terme,
si vous voulez.
Et ça, ça
contribue aux bouleversements climatiques,
donc aux aléas auxquels on se prépare.
Qui sont les fameuses
épisodes extrêmes canicules
et froids, grands froids
et les épisodes climatiques
de plus en plus intenses
qu'on a eu cet été ?
Les grandes chaleurs et qu'on va avoir
de façon de plus en plus fréquente.
Ça n'est pas un effet de pollution, c'est
contribution d'un gaz à effet de serre.
Vous voyez
les deux phénomènes ? Je distingue.
J'espère avoir un peu éclairé le sujet.
Oui, c'est ça.
Finalement,
on est dans des changements globaux.
Si on pourrait faire,
ça pourrait être concentrique.
On a le réchauffement climatique,
le réchauffement climatique
fait partie du changement climatique
et le changement climatique
fait partie des changements globaux.
Finalement, c'est toute notre activité
qui change, c'est l'économie qui change,
c'est
la culture, c'est la société, c'est c'est
nos activités et tous ces changements
globaux les uns avec les autres.
Il va y avoir une accumulation
et un impact sur notre santé,
sur les inégalités, sur la santé mentale,
la santé physique, la mortalité.
Quand vous parlez
de la pollution de l'air, finalement,
si on prend, quels que soient les pays,
qu'est ce que ce.
Quel que soit l'âge
et quel que soit le genre de personnes
dans les principaux causes de mortalité,
on va retrouver la sédentarité,
la pollution de l'air et la malnutrition
et sous alimentation.
Finalement,
les maux de notre de ce siècle.
Voilà nous
qu'on retrouve finalement avec ça.
On retrouve un côté santé publique
et environnementale.
Si on change notre pollution de l'air,
si on change la manière dont on bouge,
on va changer,
limiter la pollution de l'air,
on va limiter notre sédentarité,
on va limiter et améliorer
nos conditions physiques
et nos corps, notre santé physique.
Si on mange autrement, finalement,
on limite aussi la pollution,
on limite la pollution de l'air.
Et voilà. En fait, tout ça, ça va.
Tout est lié.
Notre activité et les changements de d'actuel, les enjeux et les impacts actuels.
Et j'imagine que justement, dans vos
projets de recherche, tout s'entremêle.
En fait, les projets sont de plus
en plus interdisciplinaires de ce fait.
Alors oui, c'est vraiment
une nouvelle manière de travailler.
Clairement,
les questions environnementales,
ça nous percute,
ça nous percute en tant que citoyens,
ça nous percute
nous aussi, au premier chef.
En tant que chercheur,
on ne peut pas rester,
regarder ces choses
qui se passent à côté de nous.
Ça nous amène effectivement
à travailler dans des projets
où on va aborder les choses à la fois
sous des angles physiques,
chimiques, biologiques
et aussi sous des angles
qui vont être du domaine
des sciences humaines et sociales.
Donc, on le disait
avec Cyril, on partage un projet
dans lequel, justement, on regarde
à la fois quel est le risque d'inondation
lié au changement climatique ?
Dans le domaine littoral,
on regarde
quel va être l'impact économique
que ça peut avoir en fonction des endroits
en fonction des activités.
Et on essaie également d'analyser
quelle est
la perception des personnes
sur le territoire
et on essaie de voir comment est ce qu'on
peut progresser avec ces personnes.
Alors on a souvent l'idée ou l'image
du chercheur
qui est dans sa tour d'ivoire.
Ces questions là, ça nous oblige
vraiment à sortir de nos laboratoires,
à venir sur le terrain,
à discuter directement avec les gens
parce que ça sert à rien d'essayer
d'élaborer des solutions.
Si sur les territoires,
les gens ne sont pas prêts à les accepter
ou non, n'ont pas compris les choses.
Et nous, on a aussi une perception
qui n'est pas complète.
Donc on n'a pas compris
ce que les gens
avaient eux mêmes appris sur le terrain.
Donc c'est vraiment une manière
assez différente de faire de la recherche
qui se développe depuis une dizaine
ou une vingtaine d'années
un peu partout dans le monde et
sur Rennes.
Les établissements rennais,
les deux universités,
les écoles se sont regroupées autour
d'un projet
qui, dans les dix ans qui viennent,
qui a été
sélectionné et financé au niveau national,
dont l'objectif est justement
de mettre en avant
ce type de recherche interdisciplinaire
et co-construire avec les territoires
et les citoyens.
Et c'est ce que vous faites
avec votre projet sur les inondations
et c'est tout à fait.
Notre projet sur les inondations
est un des exemples
de ce qu'on peut faire
de ce type de recherche d'accord.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ?
Je vois une main qui se lève,
je vous fais participer.
Ce soir, vous êtes nombreux.
Je suis sûr que tout le monde a
des questions.
On vous écoute ? Bonsoir, bonsoir à tous.
J'ai une petite question
pourquoi la question du logement ?
Elle est pratiquement jamais abordée
lorsqu'on parle de changement climatique ?
Parce que parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est en train de pousser les gens
à habiter avant 30 ou 40 kilomètres
des métropoles et des grandes villes.
Et c'est un peu ce style de vie qui,
c'est ce style de vie
là qui pousse les gens à vraiment polluer.
Donc moi,
je trouve que la question du logement
est une question vraiment primordiale.
Ça peut être le game changer
pour le changement climatique
et ça juste
avoir votre avis sur la question.
Merci, c'est intéressant. Merci,
je peux juste commencer.
Est ce elle vient de dire tout à l'heure
que ces changements, ils étaient où ?
Tout était lié.
On parle de changement systémique,
c'est à dire ?
Vraiment.
Effectivement, tous les facteurs sont liés
les uns avec les autres.
Donc il y a un certain nombre d'éléments
qu'on met en avant,
soit parce qu'on les comprend mieux,
soit parce qu'on
pense qu'on a une prise
un peu plus directe dessus.
Donc effectivement, c'est
la production de CO2.
Donc ça peut être
le chauffage.
Voilà, on nous demande de baisser notre
chauffage, ça peut être les transports.
Voilà un certain nombre de points
et il y en a d'autres
effectivement sur lesquels on insiste
un petit peu moins.
Je ne suis pas certain
que le logement soit forcément
l'exemple type parce qu'il y a quand même
une volonté et une politique
pour isoler les logements.
Donc c'est déjà un élément.
Mais effectivement, globalement,
répondre à l'enjeu climatique
et à l'enjeu de biodiversité
a l'enjeu des inégalités
puisqu'on est face à une crise
qui n'est pas qu'une crise
climatique, n'est pas
qu'une question de carbone.
Ça va progressivement
nous amener à devoir vraiment
modifier en profondeur
notre façon de vivre,
notre façon de gouverner,
de faire démocratie, de vivre ensemble.
Ce sont des changements qui sont vraiment
extrêmement profonds, qui nous attendent.
C'est à la fois très compliqué,
mais en même temps,
c'est aussi extrêmement stimulant
parce qu'on a aussi à réinventer
ou à retrouver des choses qu'on a perdu.
Et donc, effectivement,
ça va imposer qu'on prenne en compte
notre manière de vivre,
notre manière de vivre entre milieu rural,
entre milieu urbain,
notre manière d'habiter,
notre manière de se déplacer, et cetera
Donc, il y a effectivement plein de choses
que souvent
on oublie, on se focalise un peu
sur des aspects techniques,
mais clairement, il va falloir
que toutes ces dimensions, elles
soient prises en compte.
C'est ça ?
Non ? C'est ça ?
Oui. C'est une question très difficile
que vous posez là.
La première chose, c'est que l'habitat
ou le logement offre
de distinguer l'un et l'autre.
Le logement, c'est
où Est ce qu'on va pouvoir
vous installer pour trouver un toit ?
l'Habitat, c'est où.
Est ce que vous allez pouvoir vivre ?
C'est deux choses différentes.
Avoir un toit, c'est pour s'abriter,
se protéger.
Aujourd'hui,
il y a une pénurie de logements
parce qu'on n'a
pas la capacité à répondre aux besoins
de tous ceux qui sont en recherche
d'un logement.
Et du coup,
on a un phénomène depuis plus de 30 ans
qui est ce phénomène d'expansion urbaine ?
C'est à dire qu'on gros,
on a eu une tendance à mener
des politiques publiques
d'expansion ou d'extension urbaine.
Je ne sais pas lequel des mots
il faut, mais où nos villes,
Les villes ont tendance à se créer
en couronnes successives
première couronne,
deuxième couronne, troisième couronne.
Les Américains
ont fait pareil dans les années 50,
donc on ne fait que suivre un modèle.
Je parle de modèle
parce qu'on va y revenir après ce modèle.
Il est ancré
dans les esprits des urbanistes
pour dire c'est ce qui
permet, d'une part, de déconcentrer
les populations,
d'offrir du logement de plus en plus.
Le rêve des foyers avec le jardin,
un espace autour d'une maison,
la maison individuelle et son jardin,
le grand rêve.
La limite, c'est qu'un un moment donné,
vous empiéter sur des espaces
non seulement naturels,
sur des espaces cultivés,
et que plus votre ville s'étend,
plus les ressources qu'il faut apporter
aux habitants vont être à comment dire
fournir à longue distance.
Imaginez ! J'ai eu à faire.
Je faisais une enquête sur l'expansion
urbaine en région de Lyon
dans les années 2000-2005.
Un responsable d'un service
me dit qu'à force d'avoir des demandes
de propriétaires
qui s'éloignent de la ville derrière,
il faut que tous les réseaux
suivent. Intéressant.
Vous plantez votre maison à 30 kilomètres
et l'occupant nous dit
Mais monsieur, il me faut lubricité.
L'eau, le gaz, la route,
le facteur, les magasins, il faut tout.
Donc qu'on ramène tous les services à 30
kilomètres, voire demain 50 kilomètres.
Et c'est ce qui s'est produit
en 20 ans, la maison qui était desservie
a dix kilomètres.
Ben vous voyez, 20 ans plus tard,
une maison qui demande les mêmes services
à 30 puis 50 kilomètres.
Comment voulez vous
amorcer une tendance où tout le monde
a trouvé à s'émanciper aussi loin ?
On le paye maintenant, je le dis
avec des guillemets, on le paye cher.
Non seulement on coût des réseaux
et maintenant en énergie.
Et du coup,
il y a une loi qui est passée en 2002.
Je n'ai plus son nom en tête
qui était dire
il faut densifier les villes.
Donc en gros, le mouvement inverse à dire
qu'on a passé 30 ans à faire
l'expansion urbaine.
Puis, à partir de 2002,
on a senti des frémissements.
Non, non, il faut vite densifier parce que
ça nous coûte de plus en plus cher.
Donc,
vous voyez un mouvement de balancier ?
C'est
un peu ça dans les politiques publiques.
Du coup, là, on est en train de faire
un peu marche arrière.
Et du coup, vous voyez bien
que les métropoles, elles, sont devenues
des métropoles très denses
puisqu'on élève de plus en plus
des immeubles pour y mettre
de plus en plus de monde en centre ville.
Donc c'est le balancier inverse.
Est ce qu'au changement climatique
on apporte une réponse ?
Je n'en ai pas.
Je n'ai pas de réponse là dessus,
mais je pense que ça va être ça.
Mais ça met fin à ça exigerait
ou ça demanderait un travail
vraiment de recherche.
On pourrait dire un peu prospectiviste,
c'est à dire
dont le modèle qu'on a expérimenté
pendant 30 ans, on en a vu les limites.
Est ce que l'on n'a pas intérêt
à se pencher sur les 30 ans à venir
pour voir comment on va pouvoir s'adapter
aux nouvelles conditions climatiques,
énergétiques, économiques et sociales ?
Vraiment, je crois qu'il
y a un travail de prospective à faire.
Je peux apporter cette réponse là.
En tant que chercheur, je dis ça.
C'est quelque chose qui n'est pas du tout
étudié.
S'il y a des d'urbanisme
qui sont là dessus.
Mais en France, entre urbanisme
et santé par exemple, on a des chercheurs,
il y a un groupe de travail
qui travaille là dessus.
Moi, mon habilitation à diriger
des recherches a porté là dessus.
Urbanisme, environnement et santé,
par exemple, c'est de se dire mais comment
on conçoit la ville de demain à l'échelle
des enjeux environnementaux
et notamment climatiques, et en prenant
en compte, j'imagine, les inégalités ?
Pas automatiquement.
Il y a les fractures sociales.
Parce que vous voyez vous évoluer,
mais pas que.
Ce n'est pas que les urbanistes.
Les épidémiologistes voient maintenant,
on le mesure.
J'ai une collègue
qui maintenant est partie à l'Inserm
qui a fait une enquête
pendant plus de trois ans, où on voyait
les fractures sociales.
Je parle de fracture parce que
c'est une forme d'inégalité, de traitement
environnementale des populations
qui, à un moment donné, vont
vous localiser des industries qui émettent
et de l'habitat de proximité qui va subir
les nuisances de cette industrie.
Et on le voit dans l'histoire,
c'est flagrant.
Donc c'est difficile de rééquilibrer.
C'est parce que nous penser une ville,
il faut au moins pour penser pour 30 à 50
ans, c'est ça.
Sauf que là, on ne les a pas.
En fait, l'urgence, elle a.
Mais ce n'est pas qu'on ne les a pas,
c'est qu'on ne les prend pas.
C'est à dire ?
En gros, on va vous concevoir à la va vite
des villes
pour répondre à un besoin urgent.
C'est là où je pense
que l'urgence nous met dans des.
Dans les fausses, dans les textes.
C'est un paradoxe les
Français sont très bons en prospective.
On a eu des laboratoires de prospective
dans les années 80
qui étaient exceptionnels.
On avait une culture
de la planification à long terme.
Je suis désolé, je vais te dire,
mais les politiques n'ont pas écouté
ces prospectivistes
comme ils n'ont pas écouté.
Parce que pour qu'on entend dire
aujourd'hui qui aurait pu croire que l'été
dernier nous allions vivre une canicule.
Ça fait 50 ans, Monsieur le Président,
qu'il y a des chercheurs,
des experts en France,
à Rennes, à Paris, à Lyon,
à Toulouse, à Marseille, qui travaillent
sur le changement climatique
depuis 30 ans.
Et vous n'avez pas
entendu cette expertise là
là ? Qu'on m'explique.
Merci.
Finalement,
on retrouve les déterminants de santé.
Ah voilà, en parlant d'urbanisme, là,
c'est dans les déterminants de santé.
Ce sont les habitudes.
C'est ce que disait Cyril.
Comment je vis
mes habitudes alimentaires ?
Est ce que je fais du sport ?
Est ce que je fume ?
Toutes les habitudes là où je vis.
Donc je vis à la campagne, je vis.
Et puis aussi, on va retrouver l'accès
au système de soins système de santé.
Je fais le lien,
c'est un réseau, c'est parfait.
Et puis les défenses immunitaires
comme chacun
fait et finalement, notre santé va évoluer
avec tous ces déterminants.
Et donc, l'urbanisme fait partie de notre
notre
environnement avec nos habitudes.
Merci beaucoup.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Oui, mon frère Monsieur,
vous êtes peut être pour poursuivre.
Est ce que ce que dit
et essaye par rapport au système de santé
parce que les changements climatiques,
la santé et voilà.
Et on voit,
On voit qu'il y a toute une réflexion
autour de l'organisation
du système de soins.
Enfin, confère l'actualité aussi
toute toute récente.
Et on voit bien que la vous trois
sur le plateau, vous faites le lien.
C'est à dire que, en s'intéressant
aux questions climatiques,
la question de l'eau, et cetera,
mais aussi la question de la santé,
comment est ce qu'on intègre par rapport
aux changements climatiques,
la réflexion sur la transformation
du système de soins,
y compris au sens vraiment
global du terme, c'est à dire
pas seulement l'hôpital,
mais tout le reste.
Et quelque part, ça vient aussi boucler
avec ce que vous disiez, c'est à dire
quand on habite à 30,
40, 50 kilomètres, et cetera.
C'est vertigineuse
quand on sait que pour les uns les autres,
on se dit wow !
Et on commence par quel bout ?
Alors si on prend le bout de la santé,
est ce que vous, vous avez des pistes
pour pouvoir réfléchir ?
Le système de santé à venir
dans un contexte de
changement climatique ?
Estelle Peut être.
Cyril
J'ai pas assez parlé,
ça, c'est moi.
Sur le système de santé, je connais bien.
Allez, lancez vous,
je viendrai à votre rescousse.
Du coup, Christophe, tu parlais de l'accès
aux soins, c'est ça ? Oui,
effectivement, dans les déterminants
de santé, c'est ce que je disais.
L'accès à un soin
fait partie, creusent les inégalités.
On voit le système, c'est difficile.
Je ne sais pas par où l'aborder.
En fait,
on parle de développement durable.
Finalement, le système de santé
est producteur de pollutions
et lui même en fait, et c'est tellement
une grosse machinerie que ce soit
les hôpitaux, les EPAD, les centres
jeunesse, on va tous système de soins,
même la médecine ambulatoire,
l'approvisionnement des médicaments,
c'est très large, C'est tout.
Ce système de soins, c'est 8%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
national. Donc finalement neuf ou dix.
Mais maintenant ?
Parce que finalement,
même si on fait des efforts,
on est de plus en plus nombreux
et on utilise de plus en plus
de numérique, de machineries et autres.
Ce système de santé, il faut, on va dire,
on va essayer de travailler avec eux
pour qu'ils soient moins pollueurs
puisque finalement, c'est aussi
les premiers exposés.
Alors on donnait tout le temps,
on donne l'exemple quand on fait court.
Bon ben oui, effectivement,
la pandémie qu'on vient de vivre,
elle n'est pas forcément
liée au changement climatique,
mais on va être amené à en subir
de plus en plus ou d'autres situations.
Nous, on va avoir des personnes malades
qui vont arriver.
On a bien vu
que ça a été difficile à gérer.
Sauf que là, ça va pas.
Un J'ai lu
la presse, là à Noël, c'était la cata.
Là, que ça soit à Bordeaux,
on ne peut pas les nommer.
Mais Bordeaux, Metz, Nancy,
ils ont été obligés de mettre les tentes.
Finalement pour accueillir, le public
avait plus de 7 h de queue pour recevoir.
On est tellement dans un système de d'un
système de santé qui qui faiblit,
qui fonctionne plus que comment en fait
travailler avec eux sur un système durable
puisque déjà on n'arrive plus
à faire face à une situation dite normale.
Donc, et on creuse de plus en plus
les inégalités,
il y a de moins en moins de médecins
alors en région Centre, 22
médecins là bas, j'ai aperçu ça
et il y a plein d'exemples en ce moment.
Il y a plein d'interviews, de moins
en moins de médecins dans les campagnes.
Donc on creuse les inégalités,
on creuse finalement
les ça a un impact
sur la santé des populations.
Et c'est le chat qui se mord la queue
si tu veux compléter.
Et donc on a un travail quand même.
Peut être que c'est là où tu peux parler
de lâcher la chair.
Où Je veux que ça peut être intéressant
de faire démarrer ça pour trois ans.
Alors Estelle
a bien soulevé le problème déjà.
Alors après,
à l'école, on a essayé avec Laurie Marot
et c'était il y a maintenant un an,
de créer une chaire qui soit dédiée
justement à comment le système de santé
peut s'adapter à l'évolution,
à la fois en tant que émetteur de gaz
à effet de serre,
parce qu'il est émetteur comme toute autre
activité industrielle ou humaine,
et à la fois être en capacité de s'adapter
aux conditions nouvelles qui s'imposent
à lui, notamment d'adaptation
à des publics qui, peut être, vont affluer
en périodes, comme on l'a
vu par des crises et gérer des crises.
Donc la chaire qui est créée,
et justement, c'est pour comment
le système de santé peut il intégrer
et préparer son adaptation future ?
Sur les dix ou quinze ans à venir,
s'y prendre maintenant
et s'adapter justement en termes
d'offre de soins ou de capacité
de recevoir les personnes
qui sont affectées aussi.
Donc à la fois, c'est la gestion,
je dirais, des établissements
et à la fois c'est aussi
son offre de service.
On essaie de réfléchir là dessus
et vous allez expérimenter des choses ?
Oui, alors
on est ce qu'on est en train de finir des
on va dire des régions
sur lesquelles qui pourrait nous servir
d'illustration, d'exemple de terrain
puisqu'on cherche des terrains.
Et c'est ça, comme le disait
tout à l'heure Luc, il faut tester quoi ?
On ne veut pas être dans la tour d'ivoire.
Donc on va essayer d'aller voir,
d'avoir des interlocuteurs de
plusieurs types de services, hospitaliers
ou non hospitaliers un résidence,
établissement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes et autres
et voir la capacité de résilience.
C'est un grand mot d'aujourd'hui,
donc de revenir à un état de stabilité,
d'équilibre.
Après avoir accusé le choc des crises
qu'au vide
du climat économique et social.
Maintenant,
puisqu'on a des tensions sur les RH
et ça le disait, le problème qu'on a avant
même la crise climatique et énergétique,
c'est des ressources humaines qui n'ont
pas été déployées depuis plus de 30 ans.
Le numerus clausus de médecine qui date
des années 80, c'est pas d'aujourd'hui.
Il était,
il était quasiment planifié pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de médecins aujourd'hui.
Enfin, je le caricature
mais où on manque de personnel.
Voilà,
OK. Et donc il y avait une question
je crois.
Oui, merci.
En tout cas, c'est justement à propos.
Le système économique de la santé
a été un peu
très difficile en ce moment.
Mais pourquoi avoir priorisé les économies
à faire plutôt que de respecter
la santé des gens ?
Fournir suffisamment de médecins,
former des infirmières,
former des agents de santé, et cetera ?
Et les écoles ?
Les étudiants sont prêts
à donner tous ces cours là,
mais le budget de la santé
ne le permet pas parce qu'il
faut toujours faire des économies
à tout point de vue au point de vue
matériel, de soins, et cetera, et cetera
Alors, la politique de santé,
ça aurait été la revoir,
par exemple.
J'aurais tendance à dire
il n'y a pas que la politique de la santé
de manière globale, depuis 30 ans,
on est dans un système dans lequel
on considère qu'on paie trop d'impôts
et donc on
diminue les impôts, notamment
sur les tranches les plus élevées.
Les tranches maximales, c'est 45%
et on considère que c'est que c'est
déjà scandaleux et que si on augmente,
on va avoir tous les gens riches
qui vont quitter notre pays.
Et globalement
ça veut dire que progressivement,
ce que l'État possède, c'est à dire
ses écoles, ses universités, ses hôpitaux.
Donc tout ce qu'on ce que l'Etat, c'est
à dire ce que nous nous possédons
en commun, c'est appauvri, alors
c'est appauvri parce qu'il y en a moins.
Et il y a de moins en moins de personnes
à l'intérieur de l'ensemble
des services publics.
Et c'est vraiment
une espèce de trajectoire depuis 30 ans
qui s'est accompagnée en plus
de processus
qualité extrêmement administratif,
extrêmement lourd dans un objectif
d'essayer d'être le plus rentable
possible, qui font que aujourd'hui,
effectivement,
on a tous entendu parler des descriptions
un peu apocalyptiques des
des hôpitaux où les soignants
ne peuvent plus s'occuper des personnes.
Mais nous, en tant qu'universitaire,
on pourrait parler
également des situations des universités
qui sont extrêmement sensibles
malheureusement, et systématiquement,
ça aggrave les inégalités parce que
les tranches les plus riches arrivent
toujours
à avoir des systèmes privés,
et cetera Contrairement aux tranches
les plus pauvres,
l'Etat consacre davantage d'argent
aux enfants des classes
les plus fortunées que aux enfants
d'ouvriers.
Il y a, et c'est un système dans lequel
on est depuis 30 ans et clairement,
ce n'est pas qu'une question politique
au sens
où je suis en train
d'avoir un discours à la Mélenchon.
Mais c'est d'abord,
c'est aussi un certain des choses
qu'un certain nombre d'économistes
constatent
qu'un certain nombre de personnes,
y compris plutôt à droite de l'échiquier,
réalisent aussi,
sur la question des inégalités
et le changement climatique.
C'est vraiment quelque chose
qui questionne aussi la façon
dont, justement, on vit ensemble et
et le besoin
qu'on va avoir beaucoup plus important
de politiques communes, de lieux communs,
d'endroits où on va mettre nos énergies
et pas uniquement à
travers un échange marchand,
mais aussi la
façon dont les gens peuvent prendre soin
les uns des autres.
Le fait qu'on va être amené à revenir
sur la question de l'urbanisme,
à déconcentrer un certain nombre de choses
à ce que l'alimentation
soit beaucoup plus localisée
qu'elle l'est aujourd'hui, et
donc que les gens passent aussi du temps
à faire produire leur
une partie de leur agriculture.
Donc là, il y a tout ça à repenser
et je pense que ça va clairement
impacter ces questions d'inégalités.
J'ai eu un discours
un peu général, c'est intéressant.
Est ce qu'on pourrait avoir
un moment de rupture
qui ferait qu'on arrive dans le mur
et que d'un coup, comme pour le vide,
finalement, il a fallu qu'on se retrouve
sans masque confiné chez nous
pour peut être que ça bouge.
Est ce que malheureusement
vous attendez à ce type de situation
pour qu'il y ait un réveil politique
ou même social ?
Je ne sais pas
si c'est vrai que, a vous entendre,
c'est quand même
quelque chose que vous constatez
depuis une trentaine d'années.
C'est vrai que la question
qu'est ce qu'on attend ?
Mais est ce qu'il
va falloir en fait avoir le cap ?
Donc oui, exact.
Très bonne, très bonne référence.
J'imagine qu'on peut prédire.
Mais qu'est ce que vous
en tant que scientifiques ?
Moi, la première chose que j'aurais
envie de dire, c'est
qu'on a pris conscience
avec cet été 2022, un peu dans notre chair
entre guillemets, de ce qui allait venir
avec un certain nombre de scientifiques
qui ont dit OK des étés 2022,
ça va devenir plus en plus fréquent.
Donc on commence à se dire
Ah oui, tiens quand même
c'est et on a beau être en Bretagne
ou on se dit finalement
avoir deux degrés de plus,
ça pourrait être un peu sympa,
non ?
On sent bien que ça va être compliqué,
mais il y a un certain nombre de pays
où la situation, elle.
Est ce qu'on
a en centaines de milliers de gens,
en millions de personnes
qui sont déplacées, qui perdent tout
leur maison, leur famille,
leurs liens, leur pays, et cetera
Et je pense que pour ces pays
qui sont évidemment
les pays les plus pauvres,
donc ceux qui sont strictement pour rien
dans le changement climatique, eux
ils sont déjà en train de le vivre
et donc je pense que pour eux
ils sont déjà rentrés dans le mur.
Mais on a tellement de barrières
et de exosquelettes
qui ne sont pas que technologiques
mais qui sont aussi sociaux
que ça nous fait pas suffisamment bouger.
Mais on est déjà dans le mur,
au moins pour une partie des habitants
de notre planète.
C'est
comme s'il fallait vraiment le vivre pour
pour comprendre
en fait l'ampleur du problème.
Malheureusement, là, ça se rapproche.
En ces 250 millions de personnes
qui vont migrer d'ici 2050.
Donc on imagine, parce que je ne pense pas
que la Terre est plate.
Je suis désolé, mais c'est sûr,
je ne suis pas une plate.
On imagine que tout l'hémisphère
sud, finalement, remonte vers le nord.
En gros, c'est ça.
250 millions.
Donc il y a une migration vers le nord.
Oui, 250 millions.
Si on entend, on nous dit Istanbul,
faut le visiter maintenant
parce que c'est une des premières villes
qui va disparaître.
Istanbul, c'est juste à côté. Suds,
enfin c'est.
Je pensais exactement comme Luc.
Finalement,
c'est tous ces événements extrêmes.
Oui, donc pour l'instant,
ils sont un peu loin.
Nous, on a un peu chaud,
mais en Inde, c'était 50 degrés.
Il y a des gens qui vivent des tsunamis,
des ouragans.
Demain, c'est nous, c'est ça.
Là, ils sont en train de travailler
sur les côtes normandes.
Je ne sais pas. Dans dix ans,
il y aura plus de côtes normandes.
C'est proche de nous ?
Tout à fait.
À 2 h, on y est en 2 h de route.
Alors ça permet d'en parler.
La région normande s'est interrogée
depuis presque sept ans.
Je crois maintenant
sur quelle politique régionale
on peut mettre en œuvre face
au changement climatique.
C'est déjà courageux que les politiques
s'en saisissent à l'échelle de la région.
Et tu veux dire,
il y a plusieurs phénomènes
qui vont nous impacter si à la fois
on pourrait dire une montée des eaux,
mais surtout l'affleurement des nappes.
Ce qui est beaucoup plus complexe, c'est,
comment dire pernicieux, j'allais dire,
parce qu'on n'y pense pas souvent,
comment les eaux de nappe remontent.
Luc en parlera mieux que moi.
Mais au delà du la
de la remontée des nappes, c'est et c'est
là où c'est intéressant pour l'urbanisme
et l'aménagement du territoire,
c'est que ce littoral,
il a été aménagé pour de la construction
et on le voit en Bretagne.
On va en Normandie, on va surtout
le très côtes de toute la France.
On sait que la France est un pays
très côtier
et donc, du coup, tous ces aménagements
sur le trait de côte vont
être bouleversés, perturbés,
bousculés par ces montées d'eau.
Est ce que les occupants vont pouvoir
supporter
longtemps d'avoir les pieds dans l'eau
de façon récurrente
en tant qu'habitant une entreprise locale
qui s'est installée ?
Ceux qui ont ont besoin de dire oui, ça
peut être un avantage pour les prés salés.
Ceux qui veulent des pâturages salés,
pourquoi pas,
Mais il y aura À un moment donné,
il y aura une limite.
On ne pourra plus cultiver,
on ne pourra plus élevés,
on ne pourra plus produire
dans les mêmes conditions
sur le trait de côte et du coup,
il faut anticiper.
C'est là où je parlais de prévision.
Les chercheurs du groupe de Luc
et d'autres regardent
si et dans 30 ans
qu'en sera t il du trait de côte ?
Donc on fait le comptage de tous
les établissements humains habités occupés
par les activités maraîchères élevage,
industrie, infrastructures routières.
Et le coût total ?
Soit on laisse submergé,
soit on fait un retrait
de toutes ces activités humaines
et ces installations
et on regarde ce que ça coûte.
Projetez vous sur 30 ans ?
Faites le calcul, c'est
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
qui est prêt aujourd'hui à se dire plutôt
que d'avoir à payer les coûts futurs,
de se dire Ah, je vais quitter les lieux
aujourd'hui pour m'installer.
Vous voyez, on est sur les décisions
de l'échelle de 30 ans.
C'est là où ça, ça a son effet
d'avoir des scientifiques sexy.
Représentez vous
ce que sera le trait de côte dans 30 ans
et ou où sera votre installation ?
Elle sera peut être à trois mètres
sous l'eau,
lui que vous voulez peut être compléter.
Merci.
Non, non, Cyril.
Il a dit ça très bien
fait ça.
Non mais c'est intéressant.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions par rapport
à ce projet ou même d'autres ?
Oui, peu importe,
on vous écoute.
Bonsoir, bonsoir.
Je me permets de revenir
sur le système de santé,
sur l'hôpital de manière générale
et sur la formation des soignants.
Alors les soignants sont depuis
quelques temps sensibilisés à la question
de la santé environnementale.
Donc ça c'est déjà pas mal.
Au niveau des politiques,
ça s'est un peu réveillé.
Ils sont d'accord
pour faire autre chose que du gaspillage,
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gaspillage
et ils en sont conscients.
Mais on a du mal au niveau institutionnel,
à leur donner les moyens de le faire.
Parce que recycler des déchets,
ça a un coût.
Parce que
niveau hygiène, il y a des choses
à côté desquelles on ne peut pas passer.
Est ce que le tri des déchets, c'est
vraiment une solution pour l'hôpital ?
Qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre en place
au niveau d'une telle institution
pour permettre aux soignants
qui sont volontaires
d'améliorer leurs pratiques ?
Parce que jeter la nourriture
à la poubelle tous les soirs,
c'est agréable aux personnes
et on en est conscient.
Et comme soignants,
c'est quelque chose qui qui peut révolter.
Et en plus,
en étant sensibilisé à la question
de la santé environnementale,
ça perd un peu de son sens.
C'est peut être un axe
qui est traité, j'imagine.
On s'entend beaucoup là dessus.
On accompagne
et on travaille avec la nappe.
C'est l'Agence nationale de l'appui
à la performance Pour les établissements
hospitaliers, on travaille avec la FHF,
la Fédération hospitalière française.
Enfin, effectivement, comme vous dites,
les établissements sont hyper.
Nous, ça fait à peu près 56 ans
qu'on comptera trois ans seulement.
Ça passe vite
qu'on travaille là dessus
et en trois ans déjà,
le nombre d'établissements engagés
et qui veulent s'engager
a plus que triplé.
Là, ça y est, ils sont convaincus.
Les moyens, il y en a.
Alors il faut faire attention aux moyens.
La problématique des déchets ?
C'est toujours hyper compliqué
parce que les déchets, c'est c'est visuel,
c'est très visuel.
Mais si, regarde les déchets
par rapport à la pollution et par rapport
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
finalement les déchets c'est 5%.
Donc les déchets, c'est
énormément d'énergie
et énormément de temps
pour finalement un résultat.
Ben ouais, c'est pas suffisant
et c'est pas suffisant.
Mais on est interpellé tout le temps
sur cette notion de déchets.
Parce que parce que
parce que c'est visuel,
parce que peut être qu'on
peut agir dessus individuellement.
Mais on préférerait alors, parce qu'on
regarde si on agit sur la restauration
des bâtiments, sur les déchets,
l'utilisation de l'eau, l'énergie,
tout le classique, il va nous rester
pour atteindre en fait finalement
la réduction qu'il faudrait atteindre
pour respecter les accords de Paris
et rester ne pas augmenter
plus de deux degrés et diminuer de plus
50% d'eau et de gaz à effet de serre.
Il faudrait qu'il reste encore une marge,
alors je ne sais plus combien de pour 100
ou il faudrait changer notre manière
de soigner
et c'est là où ça devient intéressant.
Plus que le tri des déchets,
c'est que finalement
on distribue des médicaments à tout va.
On a des manières,
on fait des prescriptions d'analyses.
Enfin, je ne suis pas médecin,
je suis comme ça.
Il ne suis pas médecin,
je veux pas remettre.
C'est pas moi qui vais décider tout ça.
Mais finalement,
il y a toute l'écoconception des soins
qu'il faut retravailler.
Et on commence déjà
à travailler en formant les managers
qui vont être formés sur
cette problématique environnement santé,
sur cette problématique
changements climatiques
qui eux, vont avoir envie de changer
la manière de soigner.
À Rennes, il y a une superbe formation
en formation continue sur l'hypnose
parce que finalement,
sur les grands brûlés par exemple,
on les anesthésie, mais
on ne peut pas leur changer un pansement.
Donc anesthésie, anesthésie, médicaments.
On ouvre des paquets de compressions,
n'utilisent aucune,
on donne des médicaments.
Finalement, l'hypnose,
ça marche et là, c'est juste un exemple.
Je ne suis pas soignante.
J'ai un exemple dont j'ai entendu parler
et finalement
qui se démocratise de plus en plus.
Mais il y en a plein d'autres et c'est là
où ça devient intéressant pour justement
sensibiliser autres que pour aller
chercher les chirurgiens, les médecins.
OK Fautrier, les dossiers des déchets,
mais faut revoir
votre manière de travailler,
c'est l'accompagnement au changement.
Finalement, oui,
ça serait la priorité. Oui.
Je trouve
qu'on pense aux bâtiments.
On pense toujours un peu aux mêmes,
aux mêmes choses
qui sont évidemment à prendre en compte.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est pertinent
ce que vous dites.
Cette façon de soigner,
on n'y pense pas du tout.
Je ne pense pas.
Après tous les établissements,
ce qui reste qu'on
regarde à l'université ou
si on regarde le bilan carbone individuel,
le bilan carbone universitaire
puisqu'on travaille tous en université
ou dans les hôpitaux, les déplacements
finalement, et les déplacements qui il y a
la rénovation des bâtiments.
Mais là, c'est comme disait lu dans nos
universités rénovation de bâtiments.
C'est un plan d'investissement
pluriannuel, C'est plusieurs millions.
Oui, dans quinze ans,
on rénovera un bâtiment.
Donc on ne peut pas agir tout de suite.
Par contre, les déplacements, c'est c'est
plus radical,
c'est plus rapide et plus efficace.
Et le déplacement de personnes,
les déplacements de produits.
Effectivement,
il faut arrêter les low cost.
Oui c'est vrai,
c'est super d'aller à Prague
la bière et pas cher pour un week end,
mais ce n'est plus possible quoi.
Voilà
donc votre enterrement de vie de garçon.
Ça sera à Rennes.
Merci Estelle.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
N'hésitez pas,
il reste encore quelques minutes.
Encore une.
Ou peut être au fond ?
Je sais pas, j'ai un doute,
je ne vois pas tout le monde.
Ne suis je pas très grande ?
Merci.
On vous écoute
sans vraiment changer de sujet.
Je vais prendre un autre
exemple de pollution.
Vais aller dire moderne.
Tous les systèmes informatiques
avec les data centers,
ça crée quand même de la surchauffe
dans les datacenter.
Il faut les refroidir, et cetera Ça crée
quand même une sorte de pollution aussi.
On va parler des technologies
tout à l'heure.
Et les nouvelles technologies,
le tout numérique,
est ce vraiment écologique ?
Si on voit ça dans ce sens là,
avec tout ce que ça a créé
dans les datacenters pour redistribuer
l'information aux gens, et cetera
Mais bon, il y a tout
un échange et une sacrée quand même.
Je ne sais pas
quel pour centage de pollution climatique
fait, mais bon, ça fait quand même
un peu de pollution.
La chaleur dégagée.
Merci cette remarque. Oui.
Merci pour cette remarque.
C'est quelques pour 100
c'est c'est pas une question
à laquelle il est évident de répondre.
D'un côté comme disait Estelle.
Et ben
si on fait une réunion à distance en visio
au lieu de prendre tous l'avion
pour aller à Prague,
je pense à une réunion scientifique
mais qui peut être vraie dans n'importe
quelle autre
branche.
On a quand même sauvegardé
pas mal de carbone.
Donc c'est quand même vraiment
un outil intéressant.
Après,
quand on pense effectivement
à la quantité de photos par exemple
qu'on peut prendre
et qu'on a tous l'habitude
d'envoyer à notre famille, nos amis etc,
au fait
qu'on est en train de passer au streaming,
que ce soit pour écouter de
la musique ou pour regarder
des vidéos.
Là encore, on est un peu
dans un monde où où tout est immédiat
et tous nos besoins doivent être peuvent
être satisfaits.
Voilà juste en appuyant sur un bouton et
pof, ça y est, on a des milliers de films
ou des milliers de musique
et tout, tout est accessible.
Est ce que réellement
on vivrait beaucoup plus mal ?
Si, si, on perdait cette immédiateté,
cette accessibilité ?
Bah je suis pas
comme je pense, un peu tout le monde.
Il m'arrive de temps en temps d'être dans
des endroits où il n'y a plus Internet.
Il n'y a plus quoi que ce soit.
Bah, on survit.
Ce n'est pas une épreuve
absolument fondamentale, ça se passe bien.
Voilà.
Donc il ne s'agit pas toujours,
pour citer notre président,
de faire comme les amis
et d'en revenir à la bougie.
C'est pas du tout ça.
Mais justement, il y a plein de choses
qu'on peut faire
et qui au final ne nous demandent pas
tant d'efforts que ça.
C'est pas c'est pas infernal.
J'ai expérimenté.
J'ai laissé tomber ma voiture
pour me déplacer dans Rennes en vélo.
Et maintenant, pour rien au monde,
je reprendrais ma voiture.
Je vais dire je trouve une espèce
de liberté à aller en vélo,
je me douche à l'eau froide le matin.
Vous êtes courageux et bien tout le monde,
tout le monde me dit ça
et ça nous est venu comme ça à la maison.
C'était pendant le confinement
et on se trouvait.
On avait tellement marre d'être comme ça
coincé que sans vraiment l'avoir réfléchi
et sans que ça soit une démarche militante
ni quoi que ce soit.
Hé hé bien maintenant ça fait,
ça fait vachement bien.
Et même quand j'ai le choix,
je dis je ne sais pas.
Bref, ce n'est pas du tout en fait.
Aux expérimenter aussi. Exactement. Voilà.
Alors il y en a,
Il y en a d'autres qui font des trucs
que je ne suis pas prêts à faire ça.
Mais il y a plein de choses
qu'on peut lâcher et à la limite,
on regagne le fait de se dire
voilà, par exemple partir en vélo.
Ben oui, je suis obligé de regarder
ce qu'il va pleuvoir ou pas.
Et quelque part, je me reconnecte vraiment
de façon toute bête
et toute simple à un environnement.
Et voilà lâcher
un certain nombre de choses.
Et bien ce n'est pas une épreuve
et ça ça peut faire partie de la solution.
Et je pense que c'est
vrai aussi pour le numérique.
Merci beaucoup.
Est ce que oui, il y avait.
Il y a deux questions. On va les prendre.
Bonsoir, Bonsoir !
Vous parliez en matière de soins,
dévolution du soin.
Mais il y a aussi
la question de la prévention
qui est peu travaillé en matière de santé.
Je crois qu'on n'est pas très bon là
dessus
en France, sur la prévention,
est ce qu'on peut développer
une certaine culture du risque ?
Je pense que dans la prévention,
vous avez commencé par ça.
En plus, comment on peut prévenir
plutôt que guérir ?
Parce que je pense qu'on n'aura pas de
vaccin contre le réchauffement climatique.
On ne sait pas encore.
Alors cette question du risque,
C'est une vraie question d'anthropologue,
je tiens à le préciser.
Deux psychologues
Certains travaillent dessus.
Donc la question du risque, alors, c'est
comment ?
Comment ?
Comment on se projette sur la prévention ?
Oui, et après ?
La prévention, c'est comment on considère
que le danger à venir peut avoir un effet
et comment on l'anticipe.
Et donc le niveau de comment dire,
le niveau de risque
ou le niveau de danger
que je peux auquel je peux être confronté.
En fait,
il se trouve que la culture occidentale
est basée sur les sciences
et les techniques.
Et plus je développe la science
et les techniques dans l'idée
d'un progrès permanent,
comme on l'avait depuis le XVIIIᵉ siècle,
c'est de se dire
on va pouvoir parer à tous les risques
et donc on va pouvoir se prémunir
de tous les aléas qu'on va rencontrer.
Et donc on aura toujours
la réponse technique.
Et vous regardez ?
C'est pour ça
qu'on attend souvent la dernière heure
pour se dire Ah ouais, j'ai quand même
atteint 38 degrés, cinq
ou 39 degrés de fièvre
et je vais aller chez le médecin.
Voilà donc le seuil.
Voilà, le seuil de réaction est de dire
j'ai toutes les conditions pour pouvoir
bien vivre, mais c'est vraiment quand j'ai
atteint sa limite que je vais y aller.
Parce que la réponse technique existe.
Quand on est dans un pays où il n'y
a pas cette réponse là,
je peux vous dire
vous ne voulez pas comme ça en dernière
heure voir votre médecin, puisque d'abord,
vous n'avez pas de médecin, Savait ce
vous pouvez investir
dans votre environnement ?
Je pense à des pays
effectivement qui n'ont pas
tous ces systèmes techniques autour d'eux,
qui n'ont pas de numérique.
Peut être même pas de thermomètre
quand même.
Peut être pas thermomètres donc.
Donc on s'est habitué aussi
à avoir tous ces éléments de réponse.
Pourquoi prévenir
alors qu'on sait qu'on pourra guérir ?
Voilà, je fais vite.
Je caricature puisque j'ai autour de moi
de quoi me guérir.
Je n'ai pas besoin de prévenir.
Du coup,
ça nous fait oublier pour beaucoup.
Je vois. Je vais prendre un exemple
qui parle à tout le monde.
Combien de fois ai je
entendu dire par des médecins
ou des pompiers ou des secouristes
la période
la pire, c'est les vacances aussi.
Parce que ceux qui ne se sont pas
préparés, pas préparés à faire du ski.
Vous les voyez tout de suite
sur des pistes
et vous les retrouver
le lendemain à l'hôpital.
Pas d'échauffement,
pas d'entrainement préalable
et je suis rhônalpin,
je viens des montagnes
donc j'ai vu
comment l'effet que ça produisait.
Eh bien, on va secourir
des gens qui ne se sont pas préparés.
C'est exactement ça.
En fait,
on va se faire plaisir d'aller au ski,
mais on ne sait pas préparer et du coup,
on en paye les conséquences derrière
avec cette logique de réparation
prise en charge rapide d'urgence.
Donc pour inverser le schéma, là,
et peut être que là, malheureusement,
ça va nous aider.
Les crises que l'on traverse, c'est
qu'on ne pourra plus attendre
des situations d'urgence pour se dire
je vais trouver le moyen de le guérir
et là, on va être obligé
de revoir notre logiciel d'urgence
en disant il y a trop de risques à courir
pour que je me permettre
d'attendre l'aléa.
Donc je fais le cheminement inverse,
en fait, et je peux être devoir penser
à tous les risques à courir
pour ne pas justement avoir à subir.
Là encore,
il faut attendre de pouvoir le vivre.
Mais c'est un changement.
Alors je vais finir la descente.
On entend qu'entre Pologne, c'est vraiment
une question des mentalités culturelles,
Voyons, On se dit toujours
mais une société est fondée sur ces choix
techniques ?
Non, C'est la conception qu'elle a elle
même, de la réponse que ça lui apporte.
Quand vous n'avez
pas la réponse technique,
quand vous n'avez pas numérique,
il y a 25 ans en arrière, je des connus.
Je n'attendais pas dans ma messagerie
toutes les trois minutes le dernier mail.
J'attendais le surlendemain
le coup de téléphone ou le courrier postal
qui m'est arrivé une semaine après.
Donc on a changé aussi
notre rapport au temps et à la réponse.
Il l'a très bien
souligné mon collègue, de dire
On est dans l'immédiateté,
il me faut la réponse sur le champ
et donc on est dans un processus
d'accélération, je crois.
C'est ça qui fait qu'on
ne voit plus chaud de la même manière.
Donc il faut changer de logiciel
et la mentalité
seulement d'une génération en général,
au moins au moins.
Mais là, on a préparé dès maintenant.
Merci beaucoup.
Il y avait une question oui.
Bonsoir, merci pour tous ces échanges.
J'avais une petite question et un peu.
C'est vrai que c'est sur la fin,
mais concernant
on est en Bretagne
donc l'agriculture est quand même
un des gros émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre.
Est ce qu'il existe
des projets transdisciplinaires ?
On accompagne en fait les agriculteurs
sans les stigmatiser.
Je sais que c'est une grande question,
peut être,
mais je pense que c'est important
quand même de le souligner.
Parce que
Luc peut
être, avait des éléments de réponse.
Oui, effectivement, oui,
c'est une, c'est une vraie question.
l'Agriculture a plusieurs dimensions.
Dans le modèle intensif breton,
elle est très tournée sur la production
et l'exportation.
Donc c'est c'est
une entrée qui peut être questionnée.
Et effectivement,
là encore, si on veut prendre en compte
des aspects un peu systémiques,
l'agriculture,
elle, doit être pensée aussi
sur son rapport au vivant.
Donc la place des pesticides
sur son rapport,
la question des exportations,
son rapport local et global sur
son rapport au social.
Les agriculteurs vivent une vraie détresse
et se sentent très victimes
de ce que la FNSEA appelle l'agri bashing
qui est une remise en question
effectivement de l'impact
environnemental de l'agriculture.
Donc c'est toutes ces dimensions là
qui doivent être menées en même temps.
Donc l'institut agro Estelle complètera
effectivement mène
et donc avec l'Inra
un certain nombre de projets comme ça.
Interdisciplinaire.
Moi, je fais partie
du comité scientifique Algues
vertes où là aussi on est interpellés
et où globalement ce qu'on
ce qu'on essaie de dire, c'est
que les solutions agri environnementales
qui ont été utilisées depuis 30 ans
et qui ont produit
des effets extrêmement intéressants,
elles ne seront pas suffisantes.
Et voilà ce qu'on aimerait pouvoir faire.
Ce que disait Cyril,
c'est dire, est dans une prospective.
Se dire OK.
Actuellement, il y a des choses
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer changer.
Il y a une réticence extrêmement forte,
par exemple pour réfléchir
à quelle serait une agriculture
avec une diminution du cheptel.
Mais dans 30 ans,
comment est ce qu'on s'y projette ?
Comment est ce qu'on peut imaginer
de transformer ces systèmes ?
Et ça, c'est des choses qu'on essaie
de co-construire avec les territoires.
Et donc ça, c'est vraiment l'ambition
qu'ont qu'on essaie de porter
d'un point de vue recherche,
avec des approches qui sont à la fois sur
les systèmes de production sur les sols,
sur les eaux et sur toutes les questions
sociales, politiques, économiques.
Qui est derrière ?
Il y a eu
un accompagnement, alors j'ai lu
que le creyssel, je sais plus.
Si tu es, tu y es, tu es oui, oui, oui.
Le conseil scientifique
des experts de l'eau en Bretagne,
où il y a autant de sociologues
que de personnes de sciences dures,
les agriculteurs et autres,
puisque la problématique
bretonne, c'est surtout que la production
d'eau potable en Bretagne
en plus c'est 80% des eaux de surface.
Alors on a une agriculture intensive
et en plus on utilise les eaux de surface
pour faire notre eau potable.
Mais comme on n'a pas parlé de l'eau,
on a une double.
On a une double double problématique
en Bretagne.
Et finalement voilà,
il y a l'accompagnement.
Il y a une problématique très
environnement en lien avec l'agriculture.
Sur l'impact
environnemental à l'Institut Agro
on travaille sur l'agroécologie,
donc c'est une nouvelle manière de penser.
l'Agriculture
ne me posait pas de questions parce que.
Mais agroécologie, vous verrez,
vous trouverez plein de choses sympa,
mais en tout cas, c'est des grands sujets.
Les sujets des chercheurs d'une partie
des chercheurs
de l'Institut Agro et en fait, finalement,
il y a un deuxième.
Alors c'est pareil.
Ont commencé à travailler là dessus.
À l'école de santé publique,
on a aussi un impact sur la santé,
mais qui commence à arriver parce que
c'est difficile de dire je fais ça.
Donc à part on fume, on, c'est
le cancer du poumon, la cigarette, c'est
connu depuis un moment, l'alcool aussi,
les effets, les habitudes.
Mais finalement, c'est difficile.
Lier une maladie avec une activité
ou quelque chose.
Et chez les agriculteurs, à force de
les suivre,
on s'aperçoit aussi
qu'il y a des maladies qui sont arrivées.
Donc, en touchant finalement la santé,
la santé des riverains,
la santé des travailleurs et autres,
on va arriver à faire changer les choses
et les bronchites à la baisse
ou les bronchites chroniques
chez les éleveurs finalement
qui respirent toutes ces particules.
Voilà qu'on retrouve
donc cette révolution environnementale
qui va finalement les toucher eux aussi
en tant que travailleurs.
Voilà donc on a besoin ici à long terme,
on peut peu, c'est ça, C'est pas immédiat.
Effectivement, c'est
on travaille récemment,
ce n'est pas sur la santé environnement.
Finalement, c'est c'est
des sujets qui sont qui sont récents.
Très bien.
Alors il y avait encore deux questions.
On a le temps de les prendre.
Bonjour. Euh.
Ou alors moi j'avais une question
liée justement à la prévention
des catastrophes
environnementales sur la santé.
Si je prends l'exemple de Lubrizol
en 2019 en Normandie,
il y a eu l'explosion
de cette entreprise
avec des pollutions de l'air, de l'eau,
des sols qui semble être avérée
mais peut être non reconnue
par les politiques publiques locales.
Moi, je voulais savoir
quel est le poids que vous avez
en tant que chercheur ou la place
que vous avez justement pour pour
aider au déploiement justement
d'une politique de prévention
sur un territoire ou potentiellement
par exemple pour le cancer à venir
à court,
moyen et long terme sur ces populations.
Alors entre les politiques
et les chercheurs,
il y a ce qu'on
appelle les agences nationales.
Moi, je vois là, je pense à ça.
Il y a sûrement d'autres choses
finalement, en tant que chercheur,
on fait tous partie d'agences nationales.
Ça s'appelle l'Anses.
Sur un, ça, c'est Agence nationale santé.
Je me souviens plus environnement,
environnement, sécurité sanitaire.
Il y a l'Ademe aussi sur l'énergie,
l'environnement
et finalement tous ces groupes
de ces gens, ces agences nationales
dépendent des ministères, sont rémunérés
par les ministères et on travaille en fait
en tant que chercheur de la
de la publique, d'établissements publics.
On se doit finalement de rendre publiques
nos recherches.
On se doit de communiquer vers l'État qui
finance finalement toutes ces recherches.
Donc, à travers ces agences,
on est là et on impose finalement
le résultat de nos recherches.
Et on espère finalement
qu'avec les résultats de nos recherches
vont influencer via ces agences,
entre autres, on va émettre des rapports
selon des saisines,
en fonction des sujets des
différents ministères et on va participer,
Travailler avec les ministères
pour faire changer les choses.
Les sujets, c'est plus ou moins long.
Il y a la part des médias.
On s'aperçoit que des fois
les chercheurs bas,
il y a des sujets
qu'on traîne depuis plusieurs années.
Mais si les médias ne s'en emparent pas,
les l'État ne s'en emparent pas.
Donc, quand le média et les citoyens
d'où l'importance des sciences citoyennes,
si les citoyens s'en emparent bien,
les choses vont bouger.
On a bien vu
les sciences citoyennes pour le climat.
Comment ça se fait
qu'on parle du climat maintenant ?
Enfin, c'est les citoyens
qui sont descendus dans la rue,
qui ont commencé à taper
du poing sur la table.
Ce sont les étudiants
qu'on dit dans les universités.
On veut que la manière
dont on nous enseigne les choses changent,
c'est les citoyens.
Donc finalement, les médias,
les citoyens vont aider les chercheurs
à faire bouger
les choses. C'est mon point de vue.
Le fameux
triptyque, c'est important ? Oui.
Donc il y a effectivement,
il y a des relais
entre les chercheurs et l'Etat.
Des fois, il y a, on
l'a vu, sur le changement climatique.
Les chercheurs ont aussi l'impression
d'être un peu
la voix qui clame dans le désert
le premier rapport du GIEC, c'est 1990
et il a fallu
attendre 30 ans
pour qu'il y ait réellement
une première prise en compte.
Et encore, elle,
elle reste relativement modeste.
Donc il y a aussi des moments
où, en tant que chercheur,
on cherche effectivement
des instances pour pour se faire entendre.
Donc le GIEC a été extrêmement important
parce que justement
ça a permis de dire qu'il
y avait une espèce de voix scientifique.
Et face au climato scepticisme
qui qui était alimenté
financièrement et politiquement,
c'est extrêmement important.
Mais voilà, il n'y a
pas toujours ce type d'instances.
Donc, de temps en temps,
on essaie aussi d'avoir
des actions
dans notre parole, pour,
pour, pour être un peu plus entendu.
Ce qui pose aussi des questions
vis à vis des chercheurs, de l'éthique
de notre position
vis à vis de nos établissements, et cetera
Mais en tout cas, nous,
on était là ce soir.
On vous a bien entendu,
on vous remercie beaucoup.
Malheureusement, l'heure tourne.
On vous remercie beaucoup
pour pour toutes ces informations.
Merci.
Merci cher public aussi
d'avoir été au rendez vous.
Merci à l'équipe technique
au café de nous accueillir.
Voilà en tout cas un grand merci.
Je pense qu'il y a encore du chemin, mais
on va garder espoir et on va continuer
de remonter nos manches.
Cher public, on vous donne rendez vous
pour le prochain café
le 1ᵉʳ février pour parler
aliments et fermons nous.
C'est un tout autre sujet,
mais tout aussi passionnant.
Je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée. On va.